Alejandro Uribe es importador de flores
colombianas ecuatorianas en el Reino
Unido desde hace 25 años pero los
últimos tres años con la llegada del
brexit su negocio se ha visto afectado
por los trámites de nacionalización solo
Los costos se le han incrementado en un
20%
son similares los requisitos pero se han
duplicado antes uno importaba y
nacionalizaba una sola vez hoy en día
nos toca hacerlo dos veces porque son
dos mercados son dos autoridades
fitosanitarias para los productos que
ves son dos aduanas
a pocos días de la celebración de San
Valentín le preocupan las ventas porque
debe incluir el mismo porcentaje de los
gastos en los precios de las flores
provenientes de Sudamérica
ha incertidumbre Aquí van a haber
huelgas la gente está haciendo muchas
huelgas hay huelgas de transporte tiene
que haber buenas ventas opino yo pero no
va a ser fácil y los las preventas han
sido menores porque la gente está
preocupada Marc Berlín es dueño de esta
fabricante de bandejas de aluminio una
marca tradicional hace 76 años en
Londres cuyo 40% de producción se vende
en Europa luego de tres años solo ha
visto complicaciones en el negocio
antes del brexit era súper simple era
como enviar algo al siguiente pueblo de
Inglaterra nada que hacer ningún
procedimiento entonces mientras que
antes tomaba uno o dos días enviar algo
digamos a París o Berlín o donde sea
ahora puede tomar semanas y en algunos
casos puede tomar meses
al estar el Reino Unido fuera del
mercado único las aduanas europeas
exportar se ha vuelto una dificultad
para esta empresa familiar
en teoría enviar otros países europeos
ahora es lo mismo que enviar al resto
del mundo que también hacemos mucho
Parece más fácil llevar las cosas a
Francia que a los Estados Unidos
los empresarios británicos le han pedido
a su gobierno un nuevo acuerdo para
reducir la burocracia en las
exportaciones para poder equilibrar las
pérdidas que les ha dejado la separación
del bloque europeo